[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et j'aimerais savoir si
nous avons en commun
avez vous déjà eu le sentiment d'être en
inadéquation avec l'entreprise dans
laquelle vous allez travailler si un peu
lever la main moyennement très fortement
nous avons donc là même de points
communs moi aussi je dois vous avouer
j'ai été souvent de l'adéquation écrit
l'entreprise dans lequel je travaille
pourtant quand j'ai partagé ce sentiment
à mes proches à mon entourage
qu'est ce qu'ils m'ont dit tu sais le
tirage c'est pas un long fleuve
tranquille
il faut savoir avaler des couleuvres il
faut savoir subir
il faut savoir résister pour exister
dans mon professionnelle puis en
parallèle vous avez dans les journaux la
télé on vous bassine avec le piètre
travail
le bonheur au travail on vous met les
chief compliance officer à tour de bras
dans les airs mais n'est-ce pas
contradictoire
doit-on à râler beaucoup leurs oeuvres
pour s'épanouir
peut-on s'épanouir en avalant des
couleurs finalement appelé l'armée
d'aller sur scène trappier l'auxine
allemand
comment concilier travail et
impérieusement en m'amusant les
expériences passées
alors ma petite vie professionnelle j'ai
fait douze ans 12 ans j'ai fait quinze
entreprises
eh oui
sept secteurs d'activité voilà privé
public du conseil de l'industrie dur de
l'industrie du divertissement
j'ai travaillé j'ai eu la chance de
travailler avec dix nationalités dans
quatre pays différents
la belgique est quand même très diverses
en culturel en culturalité ans ce qui
est très intéressant mais bon voilà donc
là à la question finalement je me suis
posée mais la réponse est très simple
chez nous sans berg dans son livre en
avant tout certainement un beau livre de
chevet préfet a dit quelque chose qui
m'a marqué et qui m'a marqué et qui me
marquera toute mon âme à la vie
professionnelle
c'est finalement poires dans une
carrière épanouissante
il faut trouver le bon partenaire elle
parlait du compagnon de vie aujourd'hui
j'aurais envie de vous dire pour allier
épanouissement et travail il faut
surtout trouver la bonne entreprise
certaines maps et poids une entreprise
partenaire
à votre avis jeanne entreprises
partenaires c'est celle avec laquelle
vous avez vous partager la même vision
le même sens c'est changer quelque chose
à votre situation
alfred de musset et importe le flacon
pourvu qu'on ait l'ivresse
qu'importe le produit produit finalement
pourvu qu'on ait les sens
pourvu qu'on ait le sens le sens je suis
coach agir j'ai envie de changer le
monde du travail et tous les jours
pensez compliqué quand c'est difficile
je me raccroche à cette vision elle me
fait du bien
elle me donne le sens de ce que je fais
au quotidien
ensuite les entreprises partenaires
c'est l'agent l'entreprise avec laquelle
vous partager les mêmes ambitions
ces premiers états pourrait justement à
cette vision est en même temps mission
l'ambition
l'iss pour que vous preniez assez
ambitieux loser pour que vous surpasse y
est également assez ouverte pour que
vous puissiez en discuter l'entreprise
partenaire c'est celle dans laquelle
vous vous sentez bien vous avoir envie
de discuter
vous avez envie de partager vous avez
envie de recevoir de feedback alors
concilier concilier le travail et pas
doucement et que vous avez la même
vision
la même ambition il faut et c'est aussi
partager le même valeur alors quand je
parle d'entreprises biens matériels
vous imaginez bien c'est pas
d'entreprise qui vit qui les bagues
l'heure c'est que tous les
collaborateurs tous les collaborateurs à
tous les jours de la semaine à tous les
moments
vous avez des contacts avec une valeur
sans action sur sont que des mots les
valeurs ça se vit au quotidien ça ce
véhicule au quotidien si vous mettez la
valeur bienveillance il faut que chaque
collaborateur
le soir intrinsèquement n'essayez pas
faire du vin bio washingtion médias
comme on fait des fois du greenwashing
c'est pas la peine le but c'est d'avoir
un partenaire un partenaire qui vous
ressemble
c'est pas la peine blantyre faut être
honnête
ensuite une fois vous allez trouver
cette magnifique entreprise avec
laquelle vous partager votre vision
partagée la même ambition
les mêmes valeurs fortement partagé le
même monde de fractionnement du revenu
un tout petit peuple
après sur les modes de fonctionnement
notamment par rapport à l'agilité en
bref aller travailler pas glissement
s'est finalement étant une entreprise
avec laquelle vous partager la même
culture
on entend beaucoup parler d'agilité qui
a déjà pas entendu parler de
l'entreprise
il part alors j'entends souvent parler
donc je suis coach agile mon nouveau
métier
j'étais responsable syndical les jambes
agilité quand on me parle de process et
d'outils je me dis hou là là je crois
qu'ils ont raté une étape c'est qu'en
fait agilité c'est surtout un état
d'esprit plein de valeurs douze
principes je ne parle jamais process et
toul au tout départ et jeunes faisant je
vais payer un petit peu ses valeurs
puisqu'elles sont fondamentales pour moi
alors je suis un petit peu comme obélix
je vais un peu la chance d'être tombé
dedans dès le début de ma carrière
professionnelle
moi j'ai toujours mis l'individu avant
avant les pros sauce avant les outils
ce qui compte c'est le capital humain
deuxième chose c'est qu'en fait faut
faire agilité sait faire non même
document parce que je veux faire ce que
je vous souhaite préfère ce que
j'anticipe ray de faire je fais
troisième c'est la collaboration vous
certes père entrepreneur en quoi ils
tous les jours vous collaborez avec des
clients avec des fournisseurs
la collaboration elle doit être au
dessus pour justement faire au dessus de
la négociation contractuelle souvent les
contrats sont malheureusement bien
différents la réalité et empêche
justement cette règle existe
et puis un quatrième celle c'est un peu
ma préférée c'est de répondre aux
changements plutôt que de suivre un plan
bien que vous pensiez 50 en avant toutes
ces entreprises emblématiques du secteur
du divertissement du secteur de
l'automobile
plein d'autres secteurs qui ont
périclité aujourd'hui nous avons plus
bas alors que d'autres de ces mêmes
secteurs se pérennise homme d'une bonne
croissance
subsiste leur culture forcément mais
également leur façon d'avoir répondu à
un changement et l'entreprise n'a pas
répondu
elle même tout seul un changement c'est
tous les collaborateurs qui ont réussi à
trouver des solutions qui convenait à
cette situation est donc cette
entreprise a réussi à piloter
ensuite je crois profondément dans les
entreprises qui mettent les
collaborateurs en autonomie l'autonomie
nous recrutons des gens intelligents et
puis je leur dit quoi faire
incroyable finalement vous pensez que
une personne peut avoir la solution pour
les 10 ans 500 au poignet c'est faux
vous n'aura jamais la puissance de 10
personnes 20 personnes 130 personnes
vous n'avez jamais fait puis s'en sert
pour réfléchir à un problème vous avez
besoin de tous les cerveaux la vidéo de
david marqué greatness le montre très
bien comment leader peut donner une
intention lieu d'un commandant et
recevoir 100 fois plus 100 fois plus de
solution 100 fois plus de créativité
donc je crois fondamentalement aux
communautés autonomes qui ont leurs
propres objectifs et qui ont leur propre
façon d'atteindre ses objectifs
je crois également en diversité ces
équipes autonomes elles dès lundi
diverses
elle doit les diverses dans les profils
à risque
jr tous les samedis center voilà ça
c'est la diversité mais je crois
énormément la diversité culturelle parce
que vous pouvez être dans une équipe
dans une entreprise multinationale avec
laquelle vous partagez notre vision de
leurs ambitions
une valeur d'une même façon de faire et
en même temps qu'est ce que ces riches
de travailler avec des gens qui ne sont
pas de culture ça vous permet de mettre
en perspective les problématiques
complètement différemment
vous prenez du recul vous apprenez vous
améliorer
c'est vraiment tout bénef je peux
fournir également aussi des entreprises
qui à prendre leurs erreurs l'entreprise
a prenantes qu'elles qui n'a pas honte
de ses erreurs celle qu il en faire
justement plein pour essayer de réussir
demain plus vite ça c'est pas une
entreprise pareil qui le fait chaque
collaborateur doit pouvoir être en
capacité d'expérimenter marrant
l'impressionner disais en 1900 ne vont
pas nos enfants pour ce monde
aujourd'hui
car celui ci ne sera plus le leurre très
grands comme seconde main apprenons leur
à s'adapter et à expérimenter par oui
l'entreprise est pas récente
c'est l'entreprise qui vous laissent
aussi expérimenté et puis on la voit
tous les jours pour l'entente nous
sommes évidemment dans un monde qui
bouge pas forcément dans le bon sens du
terme
nous avons de plus en plus d'inégalités
on parle aussi de la de problème
climatique est aujourd'hui profondément
les gens ils veulent avoir un
tous les collaborateurs veulent avoir un
impact sur leur écosystème dépasser leur
individus dépasser leur entreprise à
voir en impacte donc laissée lors que
les collaborateurs à voir ses impacts au
travers vos laissez leur le choix
d'aller dans une cause qui leur est cher
ça va vraiment être un bâton pour vous
et également pour vos salariés s'est
aussi paré que du bonheur finalement
fait vivre cette culture fait vivre
votre vision vos ambitions vous vers
leur mode de fonctionnement
elle est vive au quotidien du début
qu'on vous appelez un fournisseur un
client
quand on parle de koestler de journée
j'ai envie de dire le monde connaît
toujours ni est important et c'est dans
tout moment de vérité est bien dans tous
les moments vous avez les collaborateurs
qui ils sont en interaction avec
d'autres collègues débiteur ou des
managers fait vivre la culture à la fin
quand un employé le par demandez lui
pourquoi demandez lui son pack mais
surtout posé lui une seule question une
seule question très simple
est ce que cette entreprise lui a permis
de grandir
nous allons faire entre 5 et 10
entreprises pour notre vie selon une
étude américaine ont grandi est
essentielle et puis même si je ne
souhaitais pas un employé qui part c'est
aussi encore un buzz ambassadeur ça
s'est bien passé si vous allaitez
l'entreprise qui lui a permis de prendre
géant vêtir pour allier travail
épanouissement il faut trouver
l'entreprise partenaire faut déjà se
découvrir puisque c'est quand vous allez
vous découvrirez vous allez savoir que
sont nos valeurs
qu'est ce qui compte pour vous donc
découvrez ne subissait pas
expérimenté dans l'apprentissage et puis
trouver beau ou les bons partenaires
professionnels
[Musique]